[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we just finished taping not one not two
three episodes three episodes in one day
I literally just walked up from the
stage just now I'm kind of beat and you
know what I could use I need a cocktail
what's our cocktail today I think we
have a poor taste creation yeah our
friends of the show poor taste out in
Nashville shout out to Porto's yeah
they've been here a few times and we
wanted something as you know we're gonna
be deep diving into the Dolly Parton
Kelly duet nine to five nine to five and
we thought would be better than to have
a dolly inspired cocktail so join us
we're putting up the screen you can make
Dolly's lime to five see what we did
there yeah working lime to five yeah so
just like Dolly it's got a strong Spirit
we have gin a little bit of complexity
in the Amaro some lime juice simple
syrup and then we top it off in honor of
Dolly with a little bit of sparkly some
sparkling wine is this mine or Jocko's
I'm gonna
oh wait that's that's for both of us
what did you feel after the last after
party Jocko oh I felt a little rough the
next day yeah I I can't lie I saw some
comments speaking of the comments keep
keep coming typing in the comments we
want to hear from you Jocko you're drunk
go home yeah so um funny enough it went
really well thank you guys so much for
watching it was it was amazing
um NBC standards and practices only sent
one representative today and they sent
their publicist to just to make sure
that we stay in line but we did have to
hire somebody we have a um a virtual
breathalyzer available
so we have our friend Destiny Lopez in
Nashville who's keeping a track on Jocko
so here's your bass line say Kelly okay
after party
no no
kellyoke after party no saying your
normal Voice karaoke after party all
right there's your Baseline we're gonna
say this throughout the show and as it
gets worse that's how we're gonna know
when it's time to lay off jockery so
we're gonna top it off with a bit of
bubbly oh I always hate doing this I
don't
shake it first yeah and then we all
right I'm gonna aim it up let's see I'm
gonna aim it up the those monitors there
let it rip
enough
and now it's a real party
so as a uh a newbie to cocktails what is
Montenegro it's an Amaro which is a
fortified wine I believe with complex
herbs and Seasonings and whatnot uh John
is really shaking his head right now I
think I made that up but it's it's
really good it adds complexity to Spirit
so cheers thank you all for joining us
cheers to you happy karaoke party and
cheers to you
oh wow that's actually good I'm
surprised yeah that's gonna be delicious
well done welcome to the karaoke after
party where we get to talk about our
favorite thing Kelly and music Kelly
Okies so we're gonna I'm Jocko I'm Jason
I don't know how we're friends but the
introvert and the extrovert he's a whole
lot of Jocko but this is gonna help me
get through it like it does every day
hopefully I won't get put in a lot of
timeouts today I'm ready for you
well let's get on with it what are we
doing oh okay so last episode it was a
blast I gotta admit I was nervous were
you yeah I was really nervous I didn't
know what to expect might have had a
little too much to drink but it loosened
me up it was super fun well the cool
thing is I was I was hoping that people
would enjoy talking about Kelly's music
as much as we did and the comments have
been amazing I mean my Instagram Twitter
everything's just blowing up and so I'm
glad to see the people most people like
we did um I think it was Nancy in
Nebraska who said that we should not
talk while Kelly's singing
[Music]
um so if you want to hear Kelly singing
without us talking go to the Kelly
Clarkson Show YouTube channel and you
can watch your heart's content for this
episode I'm sorry Nancy we're gonna talk
talk talk talk yeah now today's episode
is gonna be amazing not only because
we're talking about one of our favorite
karaoke's and we get to answer your
questions but we're going to Deep dive
into
nine to five the duet with Dolly Parton
it was so cool it was I mean she's a
legend yeah and I can't wait to I can't
wait to talk more about that and get
into the details and it was just magic
we want to see your comments too so
we're following along right here and
we'll answer some questions and we've
upgraded our budget here we have a
little iPad where Jaco can read the
comments
so without further Ado welcome to the
karaoke after party cheers
[Music]
oh
yeah I'm already pumped I'm head banging
say Kelly okay after party
wait let me practice all right karaoke
after party all right guys leave your
questions for us in the comments and
we're gonna be monitoring Emily's over
here she's watching Jocko's watching I
guess Margarita and uh and anything you
want to know and we even have Robert
here he's the guy that mixes all the
music for The Kelly Clarkson show that's
him standing in the corner right so if
it sounds bad it's his on him
so luckily today we're gonna actually be
able to play you stuff before he gets
his hands on it I'm actually going to
show you a little bit of what he does
it's pretty cool so where are we at here
producer Andy
oh what about any good comments coming
on oh I see Kaylee DW oh DW said Jocko
how many guitars do you have I would
love to answer that question but I don't
know it's that many and Kenzie Jones
wants to know when our next Kelly okay
classic is I confessed last time this is
my fault I forgot to put killaluki
Classics in this season and so we have
one coming up in two weeks we're gonna
have our first karaoke classic of season
four I like that you owned it too well I
just there's a lot going on so we're
gonna get to it uh look at Ken Smith
said Robert Venable the legend the same
one that's the mixer Robert Venable
Legend oh man it's uh it's been a big
couple of weeks for us the little two
weeks ago we did our first karaoke after
party and we came on exhausted because
we had just performed a show where we
did 47 pieces of music in one show the
Chip and Dale show yeah we weren't
allowed to talk about it then but now we
have so uh let's here let me just show
you let me show you a couple of clips
from this episode it was pretty crazy
that was crazy and I'm My Own director
here but here's hands it was crazy and
it was sexy the band will play a sting
whenever you say
you
silver
[Music]
[Applause]
so I want to point out we found out
about that we start taping our show at
about 10 30. we found out at 10 25 that
not only did we have to do a welcome to
Chip and Dale's takeover but we had to
do it every single time that he said
welcome to Chippendales takeover yep and
usually during the show I mean if you've
come to the show it's it's you'll see
this happen when they're interviewing
Kelly there's a wall of cameras we're
kind of to the side so we kind of go sit
on the couch and we catch up on
important work we're not texting family
but like we're literally well he might
be I'm clearing songs we're getting
ready for everything going up so this
show we have to pay attention we were
always waiting for the next time that
they would say thank you I should take
you guys around that's an awesome thing
to just have happen in my life Welcome
to chippendale's takeover
foreign
yes that happened about 18 times during
the episode oh yeah and then we had a
fun game we had to play where also that
morning we found out that we had to
write
sound alike cues for a fun dance game
called
um what dances go with these pantses oh
that was a great game uh and so we had
to write a little sting for that which
is this little guy right here it says go
with these pens expenses
oh I love that jingle so anyway it was
it was a ton of fun uh that's that's we
enjoyed doing that we had a little
mistake too do you remember yeah
um one of us the music director was off
to the side of the stage one of us the
music director trying to talking to our
licensing department trying to work on a
song for next week and I missed um
and now I'm hor um I can't remember
anyway anybody know what the the female
guest of the day was
she wanted to try to say welcome to
Kelly welcome to the yeah yeah and I
wasn't there so we didn't do this thing
for her and then it kind of came a thing
where we didn't do it over and over
felt really bad horrible so during a
commercial break I went and snuck behind
the couch I said Jocko distract Alex so
Jocko want to talk to Alex I snuck her a
cowbell behind the couch and I said here
you now have the power of the cowbell
and when you do this it's gonna happen
and that gave us this
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right well Lauren has a question and
we see it Lauren wants to know how long
does it take for you to come up with the
musical stings like for the Chippendales
episode and game Jingles on the show
Jocko why don't you you're you're on the
receiving end of it so how long does it
usually take us
15 seconds yeah we get them last minute
we work on them sometimes while Kelly's
on the couch interviewing something
we're writing so as a matter of fact we
can show you right now yeah let's do one
anybody in the comments give us a jingle
to write and we'll wait here just come
up with any phrase somebody wrote always
need more cowbell okay so I'll listen to
him go always can work out but always
always need more cow cow bell always
always need more cowbell foreign
[Music]
wait did we have a timer was it 15
seconds it might have been something
like that and then and then I leave this
horrible voice message for Jesse and
then she actually turns into something
singable and memorable so yep that's
generally that happens all right well
keep your questions coming Emily's going
to keep watch for us and she'll thank
you Emily yeah uh a couple of great
performances last week
um
think about I'll pick one you pick one
we always know my my favorite is
anything from the 80s
um which is not my favorite yeah no
chocolate is not like the 80s he likes
the 90s stuff yep
um yeah so we did Let's Hear It for the
Boy Dubai Denise Williams from the
Footloose soundtrack in 1984 when I was
in fourth grade and I was in my mother's
womb
I was born in 1985. man the thing I love
about the 80s is they weren't afraid of
a good modulation and this song
modulates like three or four times it
goes up it goes back down and it goes up
it goes back down and I think it's great
do we have any clips of it yeah let's uh
let's see let's check it out
[Applause]
oh this is a jam
ie
[Music]
wait did he did she say my baby is sweet
but he doesn't have much to say she did
say that that's the lyrics of song and
you're really upsetting Nancy in
Nebraska right now because Kelly was
singing and now you're worried about the
lyrics but I'm sorry Nancy but we warned
you we were going to be talking
man and check out Kyle here just focus
on the bass for a second oh yeah times I
don't really mind
oh Jason look at you handsome devil you
know what's funny is in my mind I'm
having more fun than I've ever had in my
entire life doing the song So my inside
self is just beaming and then when I
watch this footage back I mean like this
that's that's my happy face right there
and my wife and kids tell me that all
the time but Alex our executive producer
just walked in and yeah
yeah she's here for the drink
but Alex a lot though when she's she
looks she looks at my face and she's
like is everything okay there Jason I'm
like so this is my happy face this is
playing my favorite song and that's the
bar yeah well you will be too after you
drink the Dolly's line to five oh we
need a stinger and somebody top Alex off
with a bit of sparkly for her lime to
five oh yeah
work work
you heard that Andy she said talk for a
long time so oh all right there you
heard it all right do you know who
produced This Record oh man I should
know they got a little trivia wait
Denise Williams who produced it
are you ready yeah George Duke I did not
know that neither did I until I read
these fun facts from our producer Ozzy
Andy what else do you have in your fun
facts
[Music]
did Kelly pick this song for us because
we're the boys
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah as you know um we talked last
episode that we've sort of we've opened
up the requests this season so now we're
taking requests from fans from staff
members from band members yeah and there
might have been another certain music
director that was driving to work one
day and took a screenshot on SiriusXM
80s on eight listening song and saying
please Kelly's do this song
she said no the last two seasons but
this I mean at some point we're gonna
have to do every song ever written so we
might as well just do it right now do
you know how many songs we're at at this
point uh 180 songs per season we're in
the middle of season uh somebody do math
so I'm gonna guess somewhere around 680
to 700 at this point because we just
finished episode number
68 today I think wow our brains must be
just
oh there you go
how about you Joker what was one of your
highlights of well since I am uh not so
into the 80s it's unfortunate I like
rock and roll and grunge and that brings
us to the White Stripes yes Seven Nation
Army White Stripes that was fun we just
did that as a karaoke Encore because it
came from season season one yeah we did
this January 20th of season one yeah
let's see if we look different yeah
this was one of the
one that ever we had the USC Marching
Band come through I went to USC and also
my koi who's uh right here in the crowd
with us also went to USD
that's awesome
but the blonde hair
so this is interesting so you know we
did the song on tour were you on the
okay as I just said to her I've
seriously had 20 comments on this on the
YouTube of this about making fun of how
I say sure I don't know how to say tour
I've been touring for sure sure anyway
we performed this song on an entire
core
oh I see you're making it like ter I'm
trying to say like your like you're yeah
like your mom
hi Tino anyway we we didn't do the same
ways we as we did so a lot of times I'm
arranging songs I'll just pop on YouTube
and see what other versions are out
there and I came across a marching band
competition and I'm like that would be
killer to do so I asked uh I asked Alex
our executive producer and she said yeah
go for it and so I was like okay USC
Marching Band that would be awesome so
we um we actually got him down to the
show that morning and um
didn't think the whole thing through
that with a marching band we would
probably need I don't know 30
microphones or something and we didn't
have 30 microphones on the show
so last minute we all ran upstairs real
quick and I've actually got some footage
of this I remember this we recorded them
up in the rehearsal room separately
[Music]
I love that quad drummer
black oh we're in the wrong key
anyways we'll pop ahead a little bit
here
this one yeah Lester looking strong
[Music]
and he's saying wrap it up but I really
like this yeah
we can't wrap it up
but probably for legal reasons we're
gonna wrap it up right now so there you
go
um so you get to just if you want to
watch the entire performance go to the
YouTube channel and you can see it
what is it time for now the big moment
uh-oh we're gonna pop over too
[Music]
get back on all right and we're back
technical difficulties I got to use it
for the first time yep somebody didn't
turn off auto save on their camera but
hey we're gonna we're gonna do a big
GoFundMe campaign and we're gonna try to
get like new cameras and directors can
we also get um fresh batteries for iPads
or power no I charged this earlier today
we have ten percent oh it happens
well that's good time okay so without
further Ado you know what it's time for
[Music]
we're gonna have a sting for you on the
next after party this is our Kelly
karaoke Deep dive where we really jump
in listen to solo tracks check out those
soloed vocals talk over them all your
favorite things oh more technical
difficulties I touched the computer and
Kelly started singing again
yeah we're gonna do nine to five by
Dolly Parton yeah I just I just have to
I have to talk about dolly for a second
um please uh
I'm just gonna show you a little bit of
footage here this is
Dolly coming over
[Music]
here
I'm gonna back up a second so Dolly's
just standing over there she's waiting
for her cue and she turns around herself
and comes over and says hi and
introduces herself to the band
guys that's that's not completely that's
not completely normal like not all
artists do that and I you know
personally we come from the school
thought I used to wait tables I don't
know if you ever waited tables but like
I played at restaurants even when you're
walking out usually at least you say
goodbye to the server or you say thank
you to the guy at the front door be a
nice person and there's there's times
when artists don't do that and I find
that the bigger the Legends are the more
they take time to do that and as Petty
as it sounds the band we actually keep a
little running list of the um the
artists on our show that just said you
know say hi yeah give us a little bit of
love should we tell some people well I
don't know let me put my little my
little shared note Welcome to our
naughty list yeah I think NBC standards
and Praxis is getting really nervous
right now
no I want to like literally we have
pages and pages and pages of this but we
keep like Ken Jeong got a thousand
points
um Lionel Richie was a great one yep he
came over he shook our hands told us how
great we sounded killer Neil he was
awesome JoJo siwa she got 50 points for
dancing for us and so we keep just
looking for her last car yeah um Rod
Stewart got eight points I don't know I
mean we have a very fluctuating scale
happening it's just Kristen Chenoweth
got 500 points plus 100 points for
giving us cookies minus 50 points though
for saying that she preferred scones
right here but if you bring us cookies
you will get points so all I gotta say
Dolly what a legend she came over she
put us at ease I mean I I don't know
about you I I don't get nervous a lot
playing for other artists I get super
nervous doing the after party because
this isn't my normal thing but she
immediately put us at ease and um and we
showed some footage
um that that Andy put together that you
guys saw online yeah but Andy cut it off
at a very convenient point and so
luckily I had my camera going and it's
hard to hear the audio so we subtitled
it for you but I just want to point by
the way she looks fantastic she does and
she sounds fantastic
[Music]
she says
yeah you know that one
[Laughter]
okay so this is an important part Dolly
says I might screw it up though and
we're like nah nah no no you won't and
then she says it's the kind of song you
can screw up if you want and I look at
Jaco and I'm like you're not gonna put
this one up
and once again as Danny pointing out
karma is going to come back on me in a
second that's just going to point that
out anything right there so without
further Ado let's just check out a
little bit of the Deep dive on nine two
five
[Applause]
[Music]
we're smoldering
[Music]
[Music]
now this is reimagined you worked on it
you worked on it right yeah we actually
we recorded the new version their duet
in Kelly's house
um really close to here what kind of mic
did you use uh Robert what kind of mic
do I I don't know where I can use it's
that mic what kind of mic is that u87
that's u87
yeah there you go it's a Norman u87
that's the go-to microphone it's a
classic microphone Kelly in all her
albums and it sounded great so
um this this just came out maybe a few
months ago or I lose track of time with
all the stuff we're doing but
um and then we heard dolly was coming
onto the show
um I don't know about you but I just
kind of wanted to play the OG version so
we thought could we do a compromise and
blend the two together and so Kelly and
Dolly thought that was a great idea so
as you can see we sort of take over from
here and then
[Music]
damn she sounds good all right we're
gonna get back into that but by I didn't
I didn't realize how popular this would
be the the the Kelly fandom and our
staff has a huge fascination with the
click truck
which is the thing that we all hate the
most in our life is the click track so
here we're in logic and um logic is the
audio software that I use for producing
all of course and I use chocolate uses
logic as well Robert in the back who's
shaking his head and I'm gonna show him
shaking his head he's Mr Pro Tools so
um we create in logic and then it all
gets mixed over in Pro Tools by by
Robert but it would sound better if it
was mixed in logic right I mean well
so now the singer so for those of you
guys that missed last episode we use a
click track to keep us in time not
because Lester's not an incredible
drummer can't keep us in time but all
the lights all the video all the effects
the teleprompters everything is all
timed on the click yep and so especially
in a part of a song like this when
Lester's not playing Kelly needs to be
able to stay on time and needs to know
when to come in so for years we've used
this one sample of my voice I think I
recorded 15 years ago I literally have
nightmares where I'm not coming in and I
hear three four yes that one that voice
so this is what it sounds like in
Kelly's ears you can hear the click
coming in the count in and she's having
to sing and emote over this annoying
sound
there's so many click comments
oh there's that voice
[Music]
it's so much prettier without all right
no she has this
[Music]
she sounds so good
wait we're speeding up now
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we're gonna get to that but
we're gonna save a little bit of this I
want to get in some other nerdy stuff
that I enjoy yeah and we're not gonna
We're Not Gonna solo Kelly's vocals
until I hit 6 000 likes on my Instagram
page so this is a good time to pull up
our socials follow me at Jason Halbert
Jaco and we'll be here all night waiting
and I know you want to hear it we're
actually not going to do this podcast
anymore until we get a blue dot
verification
all right
let's see what uh let's find out what
Jocko's doing in this course right now
I'm just curious uh-oh so first of all
okay so here's coming into the chorus
and we're I'm nervous
let's get a little Leicester here going
[Music]
hey I sound pretty good
[Music]
we're grooving
[Music]
so you know what's you know it's not
grooving is my left hand on the piano
but if we've learned anything from our
boss Kelly Clarkson Miss unfiltered that
you you know you just you have to be
honest with who you are and so I'm
killing the B3 on the song and I have a
habit of not I think keyword players
should never play Left Hand while
there's a bass player playing because
you're competing with the bass player
both playing the same I agree I agree
yeah but in the original original
version of Dolly Parton the piano
player's just going Duncan which I've
learned now
I love but you didn't learn it for the
performance well we only had one chance
to rehearse it I laid down the piano
my right hand is killing it but my left
hand got a little more excited than my
right hand did and so it sounds
something like this
[Music]
no this sounds great
but Dolly's thought I could mess up but
check out the B3
[Music]
Jason you are my hands down favorite B3
player of all time oh that is so sweet
Jaco he knows I'm telling the truth
because I tell him all the time and in
in our rehearsals which are on the fifth
floor of the of the NBC beautiful
building we're in
um I always go that's how it's done in
one take because Jason just rips through
stuff and that's why I should do two
takes from now on when we're doing the
piano thing right there but the the
great thing about it just like in life
you look just like we're doing this it's
we all make up each other's differences
and our our strengths and weaknesses and
my left hand right now is a weakness on
the piano and and uh Kyle made up for it
so let's let's dive in a little bit more
here I want to hear somebody said a
breathalyzer test for Jocko all right
let's check in it was uh Liz C
what do I say again
because there's your answer right now
199.98.
all right let's check out a little bit
more of this I I want to do one more
little nerdy thing
this is the first time in 30 years of
playing that I've ever played a
typewriter as an instrument and so yeah
and here if you hear when the second
verse comes in
here's me playing the typewriter Luke
comes in here
I'm not saying
[Music]
what year is this typewriter
[Music]
so that was fun I always can't find a
good enough reason to put a typewriter
in a song so good yeah all right what
else can we hear what's going on we have
some horns
we had to pull out all the stops for
Dolly here's the horn sound
adding some drums on top of that
oh they sound great
[Music]
we gotta check out Kyle too
oh yeah Kyle
you know I play a little saxophone but
I've never been in a horn section seems
like it'd be a lot of fun
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let me check my socials real quick and
see if we're up to 6 000 likes yeah so
how close are we I'm sorry NBC's legal
saying that we can't tie what we're
doing to like it comes off as a
competition so just because you love us
please just front up those likes right
there all right
without further Ado yes Ken's Ken Smith
gave me a great comment he said Jocko is
vibing LOL
well no that's a lull
producer Andy says l u l l is that like
vibing a good kind of vibing yeah I'm a
Viber okay I'm A vibe guy
let's listen to Kelly sing
here we go let's see what's happening
here
[Applause]
[Music]
on and stretch and try to come to life
yeah
all right now I know for sure there's a
couple of producer Engineers that are
out there listening they're like okay
yeah of course that sounds good like
Robert put all this Reverb and effects
on it and like anybody would sound good
like that so what kind of tricks are you
doing so I went behind Robert's back and
I pulled up the actual raw audio
got a chance to get to it and we have
this
tumble out of bed and I stumbled to the
kitchen pour myself a cup of ambition
yawning stretch and try to come to life
I'll be in the shower and the Blood
starts bumping out on the street the
traffic so Robert's not doing anything
[Music]
it sounds incredible I mean I mean we
literally talk about this all the time
when we're not on camera I'm I'm
I'm a fan of her voice I think she's the
greatest singer alive in our in our
generation
and that's just she's incredible
we could dissect that but I mean a if
you've heard the original performance of
this it was down four steps because it
was a much moodier my vibey version we
raised this up to Dolly Parton's
original key which by the way I don't
know how old dolly is I think she's like
70-ish 76 76 and we're performing it in
the same key and she looks like she's 50
she's even seeing her hiring that so
anyway kudos to Kelly
and then I want to have uh we'll play a
little bit of Dolly coming in
[Music]
it's enough
[Music]
I mean as a musician you know what that
felt like to have dolly in your in-ears
you know we wear inner monitors and the
real thing yeah it's not listing on the
radio it's not listening it's just like
she's there singing it and her voice is
so recognizable it's got such a
character and she effortlessly just
threw away all these little high
harmonies up there yeah now I don't you
know I'm sure there's a few people can
notice we'll hear Kelly's voice
[Music]
and you hear in the background last time
we isolated Kelly's vocal you heard a
lot more of just Kelly he didn't hear so
much of the background noise this time
you can see they're coming out the other
side of the room and all the house
speakers are on the crowd was so loud
because of Dolly that Eddie had to Pump
Up the Volume of the house so in just
her microphone you're hearing the drums
and the band bleed bleeding in through
her microphone and Dolly's not wearing
any in-ears and for those who don't
understand what that means to find your
pitch and to find your reference in this
cavernous Cave of a stage and to find
your pitch reference I've never seen it
done like that before so so we wear
headphones and they're called in-ears
because they go in your ear just like a
you know beats or whatever oh there we
go and uh before in years were invented
everybody had what they called monitors
which were just speakers on the stage
that would play you the audio but where
dolly is there in that clip yeah there's
no speakers around her at all and she
doesn't have headphones in so she's
literally just listening to Lester
playing drums right exactly so now with
that in mind all the more reasons it's
not amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
it's all taken and no giving Pages use
your mind
[Music]
for service and devotion you would their
pictures also amazing
in harmony
won't seem to let me I swear sometimes
[Music]
can we solo that that has so much
character I love that
and what's amazing is you know Jesse and
I sit in this room and we arranged what
we think
Dolly and Kelly are gonna do and then
you saw Dolly get to the stage Kelly
gets the stage and Dolly's like no you
sing this part Kelly's like no you sing
this part we run it one time we left
really not sure who was gonna sing what
part and you see it's I kind of saw it
here when Kelly first comes in you see
Kelly deferring and doing some amazing
microphone technique pulling it away and
going to Harmony and adjusting yeah on
the Fly Like right here never give you
credit
[Music]
[Music]
such a good Melody on this song too
[Music]
okay so right here
[Music]
you're my Dolly Parton
and usually as you age and your voice
gets your voice changes over time you
lower things not not only are we in the
same key but Dolly's like changing the
melody and she's like throwing the
higher love right there and it just
[Music]
all right we apparently we have some
comments from Kelly but I don't know if
we're talking to Kelly Kimball or the
boss Kelly
so apparently we have some comments from
Kelly Clarkson herself on Clark are we
in trouble we're getting Chris was going
to cancel just us
Kelly has entered the chat
um regarding this performance she has
said that her she's referencing her
casual walk with her hand in her pocket
it's a saunter can we pull it up yeah
let's let's pull up Kelly's um casual
saunter
you said she's referencing it
foreign
[Music]
also though Kelly you're you're paying
attention to your hand in your pocket
and I'm paying attention to Ray Montero
the best Trumpeter in in La who's using
this moment to clear his spit valve on
his horn watch right behind Kelly
such as Nikon clears the spit here he
goes
[Music]
he's busted musicians pay attention to
oh there's a goop of spit falls to the
floor incredible
um Kelly is also saying I'm so nervous
dolly is incredible she has no idea how
she could hear a picture timing it's
crazy it is crazy she also uh calling
out the typewriter sound she said we
should slide the typewriter sound on one
of the new songs on the new record oh
haha just kind of started sweating a
little bit because I thought producer
Jason's got some work now
you've played me some typewriter uh
behind the scenes before too when you
had some you know messages to share yeah
once I uh musical messages so actually
nine to five was the very first
karaoke we ever performed season one
episode one
and on my keyboard setup I have like all
my favorite sounds which uh my orchestra
hits my horns roads but I keep that
typewriter up and then sometimes when I
get a little frustrated with some people
on stage I pull up my typewriter sound
and I type a little letter and I'm like
here so and so I would have loved a
little more heads up notice more
happening right 47 cues for the
Chippendales with much love Jason
like that on the show yeah it's like uh
Fallon does one with the pen where he
goes yeah we'll call it passive
aggressive typewriter passive aggressive
typewriter let's write a sting all right
we're getting circles in the air here so
what else do we have any more from oh
we're good I want to listen to the song
One More Time okay can we do that let's
uh producer Andy said we have to wrap it
up and go to Fan q a but
I will we can uh
we'll play it for me we'll play from
here to the end and the end was fun
because
um we ended it we rehearsed it four
times and we ended it four different
ways and so the ending was always a nice
surprise and so I like the way this one
ended up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give you
away
shout out to Robert this mix really is
great
oh the vibe on that I don't care what
they call it
[Music]
[Applause]
the bag awesome awesome did she say
thanks to the baby she did because she's
a Class Act Legend and she appreciates
her her servers yeah and that's what we
are we're like service for the artists
so
thank you Dolly you're incredible you're
out of your drink
champagne well um we've had some last
minute additions to tomorrow's three
shows so I need to not have a lot more
to drink so that I can focus on another
incredible piece of music tomorrow yeah
me too that's what I was yeah just a
little bit of refill in the meantime we
have some fan questions but I do want to
check in with our um our virtual
breathalyzer Destiny uh can you give us
a number on how Jocko's doing he's going
to say Kelly okay after party
um Kelly okay after party I think that's
pretty good yeah I should drink some
more yeah we should we need to oh do we
have it oh we're running out oh thank
you oh did we save some for Alex
you get a little bit slurry and my tell
is I get a little more Southern it
really comes out man it's really nice to
have this drink right here talking about
the Kelly okay after parties yeah so
this is my favorite Jason of all time
all right let's go to the fan question
everybody
yeah we do should we write one real
quick not today okay next time if you
tune in next week we'll ride a sting for
this all right we're looking in the back
here we got Emily what's up
um got some fan questions from
throughout the live uh my favorite might
be from Sabrina does Kelly ever look at
you guys and just go that was terrible
I've never heard Kelly say that was
terrible
and I don't like that Kelly's watching
right now oh my gosh if you're out there
that would break my heart and and Trish
is texting me saying that they're
commenting so
um I don't think Kelly's ever said
um that something's terrible but nothing
puts but has it been terrible nothing
puts fear into this musicians on stage
more than when you hear Kelly laugh
because she will acknowledge she does it
to herself too to be fair Kelly does
herself but nothing slides I mean like
if I hit a long little Frank are you
doing she hears it up like that and you
hear her singing and then the little
giggle comes out she's like like you
know it's been heard and then you
correct ah Savannah Keck said y'all are
never terrible oh thank you Savannah
Keck that's because Robert Venable makes
us sound great and you only hear our
final take
you said please say my name Harper
lollipop what's up Harper
um Ken has a Ken has a random question
how often is
Ken Ken Smith um how often do you all
just randomly Jam together
oh
what's funny is we season one we did a
lot of jams and we actually made an
album of our jams you can find it on
Spotify right well we tried but Spotify
um there's a there's an issue with how I
didn't know this every song has to be a
minimum length and so we had a couple of
jams that were like six seconds and they
didn't like that so those were the best
ones yeah we need to release it we used
to jam a lot more but then Kelly or
somebody on stage said it was kind of
distracting while they were trying to be
briefly no no it was probably Alex or
something like that
um six seconds though would be perfect
for tick tock yep maybe we should
release them on Tick Tock but the band
let us know if you'd like that the band
jams upstairs probably once or twice a
week during lunch breaks um I'm down
here in the office working so I don't
get to jam as much but we do we do Jam a
lot we had a great gym on stage today
well we did actually we the spirit moved
us we we got to full like it was because
of Terry Crews usually we play our
little bumpers and the audience is
sitting there going oh yeah let's go
next thing but all of a sudden Terry
Crews looked over and started jamming
with us and then we just we played for I
think like two minutes and we took it to
church
Church all right what next we got M
Night Margarita oh we've got so many
questions
um about that horns Alex Duda in the
house they want to know Jason Alex says
Alex has entered the vibe room uh how
much rehearsal time Jason did you have
with the horn section do you work with
them regularly I feel like these are the
horn players asking and they're being
passive aggressive about it
um because we get zero rehearsal with
our horn section they're just they're
that good these guys used to be um they
were part of The Tonight Show band they
played on Kelly's albums the last three
albums
um uh for nine to five oh I need to see
the video to make sure certainly just
before I embarrass myself once again let
me just uh who are horns there
after I called out
I want to make sure we got the right guy
here come on
sorry this time we uh so that's Miguel
gandal and he's actually the music
director for the mask singer yeah and so
um and he's the guy that um he's the guy
that I call to put together the horns um
he hasn't been available as much
recently but we were so excited to get
him for Dolly that's Ray Montero in the
middle and fun fact about Ray he played
on our Pilots yeah yep and he's and
that's arm Navarro he's uh he was
filling in for one of our other regular
horn players but yeah these guys show up
they literally get zero rehearsal with
us we don't even get one run through
with them and they're usually rehearsing
while Kelly's uh in Glam um backstage
and hopefully we get one run through
with them yeah we sent him a ref and I
just know I can trust him who does the
arranging
that's a great question I just send them
the reference and then like magic they
show up yeah that's okay they send them
a song and they make it themselves yeah
amazing that's so cool anybody else
oh what Alex Alex's brother oh yeah
here's one for my brother
um Jason friend of the show here how
difficult I'm glad he's a clear old
material by the babies from the late 70s
okay so for everyone if you can do it
first of all is the baby is the name of
a band yeah
I can imagine be that difficult then
because I I mean I've just I don't know
let's find out all right that sounds
like something the song is called queso
he'll he'll make you queso oh oh I love
queso so yes let's say hey Rachel's back
hey Rachel
M Night Margarita can you throw us
another couple questions oh yeah we
have
questions
um I think we covered this under click
track but what exactly plays in Kelly's
in-ears and somebody else added it must
be extremely annoying because I see so
many people pulling them out all the
time yeah there's actually a couple of
again I hated that Kelly's watching this
I feel like we just got another message
from Trisha Kelly here we will do
anything for her brother's case you
[Laughter]
got it Derek
I'm sorry I got excited about okay so
what was the click track question
um
I can't remember who asked this but
they're wondering what exactly plays in
California
there's a really funny YouTube video
it's a compilation of probably 40 to 50
National performances from Kelly early
on a career where she pulls her ears out
like by the first of everything there I
just I have to say in defense it's you
feel like you're in a fishbowl sometimes
like even Jocko and I we we spent a lot
of time trying to figure this out
because like producer Andy's wearing
headphones right now the thought of
trying to talk to you like this is just
spooky so I don't know how anybody sings
because everybody at home was through
this little education right now
everybody at home think of your favorite
song in your mind
and now saying a little bar of your
favorite song in your mind holiday that
that was mine oh no no you're supposed
to do yours I was doing mine
now now stick your fingers in your ear
and do the same thing
it sounds completely different that
sounds better that's what your inners do
but now imagine pumping in yeah it
sounds better but now saying that with
just this happening
but I can't hear the click anymore yeah
exactly so I'll say so so that's when
you see artists pull their their ears
out because they're actually they're
they're trying to find the balance
between hearing themselves and feeling
the energy of the crowd and what's
happening in the room yep and then the
um you know as far as what Kelly hears
from it it can vary based you know she's
usually the first thing you'll hear her
ask if you're in the audience is what's
giving my my pitch reference so
sometimes it's piano sometimes it's
guitar and so she wants a little bit
more of whatever's carrying you know
one more last one last one
of the night
how does that happen it's like magic
bonus Dolly Kelly
yeah we're not going to read all the
comments Kelly yeah
we're being echoed by our boss
sounds like a big question Kelly
uh last question of the night so we as
always we get lots of requests for songs
Kelly okay requests I'll pull this all
together for you but somebody really
wants to know if there's any rap or
hip-hop in the karaoke queue uh we just
did one that uh it was awesome and it
was not yeah
that's rap and we've done a few of them
before reimagined it it was great but I
will say I mean you keep asking it is
possible to wear Kelly down because I
finally got hopelessly devoted to you a
couple all skate and that was a it's
gonna be enough when I was in high
school today The Chronic 2001 Dr Dre
was the album any car you got in you
were bumping The Chronic 2001 or
incubus's Morning View
or holiday borderline into the groove no
yeah
we had different challenges you know Dr
Dre very different childhoods
yeah Jack and I were bonding one night
over drinks about we both grew up in in
trailers in trailer parks and so I
thought oh wow I've got a lot in common
with Jocko and he showed me a picture of
his trailer and my yeah we don't have a
lot in common Kelly just said I love Dr
Dre let's do it yes let's do it Kelly Dr
Dre we'll figure it out oh I'm so
excited if you need me to wrap any parts
Kelly I'll do it
well we're getting a major wrap up right
now I think it's actually Kelly who's
texting right now saying thank you all
for checking us out yeah we enjoyed it
yeah I I hope you guys enjoyed as much
as we do your response has been
incredible and uh just keep telling NBC
and the Kelly Clarkson show how much you
love hearing us ramble about Kelly and
one last check-in Kelly Clarkson show
oh I had to burp yeah Kelly Kelly
Clarkson show yeah.com but that's not
you asked me the wrong word what now you
oh no breathalyzer
the the Dolly's climb to five thank you
to all of our staff for coming in and
joining us today we appreciate your
support
and hopefully we can have more people
coming by and I can't wait to see what
next uh so I did the last two cocktails
this is your turn okay for the next
after party do you like Straight Tequila
No
no I'll do some research so leave us
your questions
um put put things in the comments send
us to Instagram we want questions there
Twitter verify US on Instagram please
yeah ten thousand all right and we have
some amazing Kelly Okies coming up I
wish I could look so good I hate that we
have to keep so many Secrets but uh it's
part of what we do and so I mean we're
gonna have we actually have two amazing
ones that I've been waiting for four
years to do and uh can't wait to hear
you what you think about it
all right so avoid
that's a good Mouse in your French now
okay all right goodbye goodbye thank you
guys so much
love you guys thanks for watching and
thank you much see you in two weeks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]